[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to week seven of the protest
League I am st. Louis Archbishop manager
Michael Jake Hummer alongside me
Grand Master for a Cobian hello Mike
hello everybody
it should be a very exciting round yes
so we are going for a perfect season
today seven and Oh
we are favored in all 16 matches against
Brazil but they are putting up for
grandmasters against our stack team of
427 hundreds so it should be a great
game today hopefully we win if we win
we'll be Western Division champions as
you see understanding site there are the
standings so Canada is right on our
scales and but if we win we control the
destiny yes exactly exactly and then
rounding out the field is New York
California and if Chicago wins today
they'll get in as the 13th seed and yet
so big big stakes on the line today so
if we win we'll get our first round bye
and then we'll play in the quarterfinals
hopefully win that and then we'll be are
on our way to a slow Norway in the final
four so oh man if we get there it's
gonna be a seem like nothing else it's
gonna be a chess Party 2020 it says in
Norway lose or draw
Fabiano Leslie and the world champion
Magnus Carlsen will be obviously there
in Oslo and it's going to be it's gonna
be like nothing else nothing you guys
have ever seen before and obviously
we'll be playing live the players will
be wearing noise cancelling headphones
and so everybody can cheer and and boo
possibly some of their moves
and if I was there in San Francisco last
year it's a lot of fun you were there
yeah was the first year the first year
very very exciting and definitely if
you're nearby you should you visit and
check it out in person it's gonna be
it's gonna be awesome yeah yeah it's
gonna be May 21st through the 24th so
get your tickets now and a book book
your hotel rooms and hopefully the
Archbishop's will be there and
representing st. Louis strong so the
format for today is it's four versus
four all play also our board one Fabiano
will play their board four and then the
board three or two board one and the
first one to eight-and-a-half wins gets
the ten points for winning the magic
correct yes and then you get additional
points we got a win today because I mean
Canada if Canada wins today they'll be
at one 21 and a half and we'll still be
stuck at one 24 and a half so we can't
we can't we can't take Brazil lightly I
was thinking about this earlier today
the New England Patriots
you know they won like they're a dynasty
we're a dynasty they're a dynasty
they've lost at home to the Miami
Dolphins the hapless dolphins in week 17
and that messed up their whole playoff
structure they had to play Houston in
the first round instead of getting a
first round five and then he got blown
out so we got it we got to take this
team very seriously that's why we're
going with a strong line-up right you
know very strong line-up to try to
finish the job to follow the games right
and we go to you need to log in and go
to today and then we we will click on a
protest League hopefully Jeffrey song
Jeffrey X we have to go sorry live TV
sorry yeah so we have to you have to go
to just that counts and then just fish
TV
and here will be the moment of truth
this is the best way to do it this is
Ben Simon wait I didn't dress for the
stream today how to producer here today
and then you go over in the next column
to chest-to-chest TVs and then you click
on arch archbishops
so again you go today you hit the chest
TV on the very top there are two chest
TVs one on the bottom but you hit the
one on the top and then you click on the
archbishop's here boom and then here we
are and and these are the games have
started or let's take a look at the
pairings our board one is Fabiano car
you anna is playing a former Webster
student Andre dear mom heavy favorite
we're heavy favorite on that board
against
maquette areum Creek or armenian
actually Armenian descent Armenian from
Brazil born in Brazil Creek or Mac
Italian friend of mine is a Grand Master
around 25 50 raining so again we are
heavy
with linear being 27 ad or 50 so we're a
heavy heavy favor did you notice one
thing when linear plays as black he'll
be black in this round he likes to go
for the Berlin and just take that raw I
think they'll be happy to draw linear
linear is very strong so drawn linear
okay then we have Wesley with white
against Lewis Powell or soupy I don't
know that clear probably younger
grandmasters I don't know his ranking
but again Wesley is heavy favorite there
I do know the next appointment of
Jeffrey Jones is a Raphael ikaw this is
a very strong an experienced Grandmaster
he's much older now probably in his
early forties I've played Raphael a Tao
so he was over 2600 it's a serious
opponent cannot take him like a very
experienced opponent Raphael later but
of course Jeffrey's in great shape and
he's a fantastic rapid blitz player so
he is heavy favorite there as well 23
years old and we got games we're off
here and we have so we have Geoffrey
Zhang Geoffrey strong is facing Raphael
late ow and we have again this is ten
minutes for the whole game with two
second increment sometimes come into
play absolutely and the way that this is
a excellent way that's suggested by Ben
Simon see this way we can click on the
bottom and switch very quickly see yes
so this is exactly a very nice way of
following all the games you can click on
next we have the rest a straw game
against GM soupy and we have I guess
they all know they all wanted to play
the nimzo-indian
Jeffrey got names of Indian and soupy
try to play the names of by the West
they said no he played nine f3 and
stopped it so then we have this Queen's
Indian interesting so a tree now plate
they're moving very fast because this is
theory and okay I think white why should
be probably slightly better here so
let's look at the next same so this is
the game that we think may be linear
with a solid so this is a game linear
playing block against Mac Italian
exactly 200 points now separates these
two players Mac Italian 2563 linear at
2762 so very solid opening so we have
this set up and it transposed very solid
said I would be for linear linear wanted
to play his favorite semi tirage
unbelievable unbelievabl long castle
this is unexpected Mike why did he
choose that this definitely shows
aggression I mean definitely a risky
risky move but let's see let's see he
wants too many play H 5 H 4 that's a
good thing you know just a safe move put
the king of it and he's getting ready
getting ready to push that H bomb H 5 H
4 at some point
that's what linear is going to do I mean
but it's not so easy for white to attack
here because you don't have a tree you
don't have before now 92 by Mac Italian
he's trying to bring the Knight to f4
perhaps so the question is what is
linear going to do now is it gonna plant
the knight only force is he gonna do
something like that and then play f5 g5
h 5 and push everything like perhaps
that's what he wants to do push
everything yeah so let's take a look at
came to see this is a game of Fabiano
Cara wanna block against Andre D amount
and this was a English c-45 and we have
96 Bishop d2 and d4 play by the amount
again huge difference almost 300 points
separated these two grandmasters so we
are counting on Fabiano to you know to
score a full point in this matter but
again GM vs GM match up Mike you never
can be hundred percent sure you know any
GM could have a good day and can play
his best and then even 2800 opponent
that I have a hard time so definitely
cannot underestimate this team from
Brazil do they have any chances of
qualifying eliminated the other the only
team in the Western Division that has a
chance
Chicago is a norsu cago currently has
the 13th seed but they need to to win
this day and and have UK not upset
California but the good thing about
Chicago is they're playing Argentina
which is at the bottom of the bottom the
bottom of the box what about the feast
place from the other two divisions are
they gonna qualify unfortunately they
cannot because their their performance
rating is too low actually it's very
strange how this could happen
it is you okay wood wood wood finishing
fifth a Western Division and hungry
finishes fifth and they Eastern Division
they would qualify because they have a
higher performance race not the point
it's not the point
for that for that fifth spot there for
months this performance I guess UK has
no chance
what about this Italia Italy gladiators
they have any outside chances Italy
gladiators well they could win it looks
like and Sweden could lose or Norway
could lose and they might be able to
Omaha weekend as the fourth-placed and
Norway Ginosar do they have Makos
display luckily Magnus is not part of
the
protests like this year so can he play
in the final store no no he is
ineligible in alleged business so even
if he shows up and says put me in coach
nope for normal they cannot put him in
right and and if we win the Western
Division will be a first place and
obviously get that bite will be playing
the winner of the the third-place team
in the Eastern Division will play the
third place in the Central Division in
that first round of the playoffs and
then will play the winner of that game
in the quarterfinals so we really want
to see who finishes third place in both
divisions and the eastern because that's
who will be playing one of them to get
to Norway so there will be four teams in
the finals correct yes final so be the
winner of the Western right each
division or it could be it could be
anybody because in the first round the
Western will be playing the east race or
central I see I see they'll be out of
conference match up so I see it
theoretically there could be four teams
from the Western Division so it could be
it could be tres brass New York and
California yeah let's go back to Jeffrey
maybe we'll see how she doing so Jeffrey
is white against Rafael late-late how
here solid we have very solid position
solid the nimzo-indian here and so
Jeffrey is trying to claim a slight plus
here Mike site plus in this opening I
like his position but it's not easy to
break and o'clock differential is little
bit surprises me differential y is maybe
Jeffrey logged in late it's possible
it's possible but let's see this is the
top man Leto is their top man by far the
most famous and experience Grandmaster
in Brazil yeah absolutely so this is
this is a key matchup here so let's see
you Jeffrey can figure out a way to
press here he is slightly better against
later
but little bit worried about the clock
he's just down two and a half minutes
here so he's got to pick up the pace you
know maybe b3 might be 383 before
prepare prepare you know we should be
for this should be for wow look at that
move I didn't expect that one okay
so more or less balanced game here let's
switch to see how our other game is
going so we have Wesley saw with the
white pieces with slightly better and
trying to press Grandmaster supey and
now we have some pressure here but the
question is how to break through black
is solid here clock difference again
most important thing is the clock first
we look at the clock six minutes versus
six so not a huge difference there and
maybe just need to build up here you
know rook Fe Wan some Bishop h3 ideas
can he do something like this Bishop HD
get some pin going look if you want put
some extra pressure so you know and he
does it he does it look at that
dissipation instant reply by soupy huh
so again not easy not easy yet but let's
switch up to the other games Domingues
game oh this is interesting here so
again a Domingues he spice it up he
didn't have to go long cos he could to
play short castle playable position but
he spice it up by Boyle own castle and
that shows his confidence here and now
we have some maneuvering going on and of
course he pushes the H bonus Mac Italian
is trying to blockade f6 the point of f6
he wants to control the e5 square he
doesn't want the night to jump only 5
because after he jumps only 5 he's gonna
try to go to c6 some kind of idea so he
wanted to just stop that permanently and
now he wants to play g5 h-hold but
before now by Mac Italian and now he
wants to play this tricky move Knight c5
sacrificing a knight and if you capture
he takes back but domain is just Grubbs
the pawn
okay six and a half minutes Formica
tarean for 74-47 for Dominguez and he
just grabbed upon quit afore I think
he's just gonna return so I don't know I
don't see it I don't see a very
dangerous compensation here so I think
it's okay you know
now the bishop on b2 is under attack and
he's got some g5h four ideas coming up
ya know he's solid it's gonna be very
hard to break through in there at the
right time he's gonna play g5h four he's
still gonna try to attack he's still
gonna try to attack so so keep that in
mind
Bishop e3 is there a trick with Bishop a
tree no luckily he can just take so
Bishop a tree here he can just take
Queen c7 this is very important because
there could have been unpleasant
surprise you know all right so it looks
like you know he's gaining that time
back here and and there's a huge
matchups today we have he karo playing
Greece Chuck is playing onigiri very
handsome
so everybody's is a huge last round
matchup here so of course we're gonna
we're gonna focus on our match but you
know it's a last round
hey Joseph is playing as well but before
New York or New York New York gasps yes
yes there's part of our bronze medal
team exactly when eighteen and now let's
take a look at this position this is
Fabiano is block and he's down upon Mike
where did he sack the pawn wait a minute
okay so so CD he decided to take and now
okay what Inc White is probably doing
okay after the opening but 95 just
sacrificing upon here and now
b3o Kate's but I trust Fabiano if
Fabiano thinks he had through yeah are
more comfortable he's ahead on the clock
he's ahead on the clock that's a good
that's the important plus he's ahead on
a clock and he he believes that this is
gonna he's gonna have enough
compensation so not easy and as you can
see the clock is ticking you know and
there's only two second increments so
it's not that much time so he is
planning to Rema new ver riemann over
tonight on c5 and put pressure on b3 and
put pressure on a for Bishop absolutely
okay so couple of moves has been played
so Queen a 390 h4 play by Mac Atari on
trying to go to f5 and no Mia is
defending it and now Mac Italian is
thinking about four minutes for linear
about by the same four minutes for Mac
Italian now he is pushing he's pushing
the strong knight back and E for oh this
is gonna be a wild one
this is gonna be Mac Italian is not
backing down he sacrificed upon he
continues to attack so let's see if
linear can figure out some good defense
need to get some control he is up upon
he just needs to control the position
again don't don't expect eyes this to be
a perfectly played game is it just
fast-paced game there will be some
inaccuracies but the person who makes
the last mistake the biggest mistake is
probably the one who's gonna lose okay
so it's just it is they're not gonna be
able to play perfect chess with three
minutes on the clock so exciting you
know
absolutely so now look fe1 and let's see
what we have here
what can linear do here you know I've
kind of want to bring this nine three
six to get some more defense just to
make sure he's a minute down on the
clock so let's see what he can do linear
is an excellent defender so he has
proven that many many times in the
difficult positions and even when he's
really long o'clock he can still play
well so so we've seen him do that
should we check Wesley okay so this okay
what happened here some development
happened here and she looks like Wesley
1 upon and now Bishop c6 takes Quincy
695 Knight f4 takes takes rook AC 8 so
let's leads up upon your rook c3 he's
just up upon here and then okay so now
black is getting some activities here so
II for d5 now look c8 oni-chan our good
friend here so very exciting start so
far
so now rook c8 and now what to do here
so it's the first round and approaches
sleek match just started yeah just
started so look see it
I think Wesley is better here Mike just
figure out a way to break definitely
black is trying to play some hoops III
but still you have rock d1 ideas against
Knight f4 so he's trying to put a night
on e six 496 and try to create some
chances okay Knight f4 and now the idea
to go to e6 and if you trade quiz then
endgame he's gonna be winning so they're
both down to about two and a half
minutes but I think Wesley is doing
great
yeah maybe rocks III I think he will
just go Queen g4 yeah rooks a tree he'll
play queen g4 and he will get a queen on
e6 maybe Queen the p2 or a two and then
preparing yeah yeah it's possible
c2 is played yes trying to get some
contra play but now let's see here nine
eight five here's a queen III check okay
there is a threat now my there's a queen
three thread this needs to be taken care
of because Queen III check now is gonna
take the pawn on e4 so it's of course
Wesley has a draw anytime he wants here
he came to play Queen e6 but he's gonna
try to figure out a way to win this we
you know we know Wesley he's and try to
push
hmm Queen f3 yeah but this is who's this
the position we had right flood so we
won Geum soupy will to zip a 2-0
Sebastian Sebastian 1 begin and Wesley
one as well yeah he might have little
bit spoil it now Mike but might be a
draw this was after oh well take a draw
we'll take a draw it's we're up by 2 up
by 2 already yeah draw is in a pocket
here the question is difficult are Ian
but you know we'll we'll take a draw in
this one it's fine we're happy to win 3
you know 3 1 or 3 and a half you know
let's see don't bother the rule just
just just take the nightlinger this
you're not gonna win this just take a
night and let's avoid any accidents you
know so let's take a look quickly if
Jeffrey a Jeffrey's in dominant position
here he's up upon his King is on d7 so
looks like a tree in half here looks
like a tree in half my excellent story
excellent start to set the tone to set
the tone for a big victory here in this
matchup here so king c6 and two now just
see just getting ready to push the D
pawn push push push
yeah just simply push push him okay take
the pawn he wants to have to connect it
fastball so he's taking more pants okay
that's a little bit different approach
I would I would have just pushed the
pants in Queen but he wants to just take
all the pants of Rafael a cow
yes another victory here playing my
goodness he doesn't want to give up a
draw he is hoping he can win this Wow
Wow he's hoping that he can somehow win
this Mike I don't see either I don't see
either how he can win this it looks like
a draw but so we have won all the
matchups so far let's see here yeah now
it looks like this a pawn is gonna come
off the board so okay we have a
repetition and that's this game ended
kind of surprisingly because we were
here and looks like his opponent just
something happening just forgot to make
a move yeah because we don't have any
more moves after Luke g1 something
something must have happened with his he
got disconnected but anyway three and
half half for archbishops yes so join us
for round two coming up momentarily but
we'll be right back for that as the
archbishop's are off to an amazing start
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level be
surprised be intrigued be delighted the
world chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
that you we get your autograph of course
I think it's pretty cool that you love
chess so much we love chess too I join
school chess program and gotta meet a
real-life Grandmaster I had this big one
time I put a police captain after school
and chickweed him in 27 moves Wow
I should be asking for your autographs
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org the st. Louis chess
club hosts the 2020 US Championship and
US Women's Championship April 8th
through the 25th these national
championship events feature 12 the
strongest chess players in America
competitors will battle for a combined
prize fund of nearly 300,000 dollars
qualification end of the world
championship cycle and the coveted title
of US Champion
first round to play begins April 10th
that's the st. Louis chest bubble watch
live at the club or at US chess champs
calm
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round two of the
Archbishop's vs Brazil on this
Presidents Day of all days a holiday and
please invite your friends to join on
with the celebration we are up three and
a half how after the first round and it
was a very commanding commanding victory
and both Jeffrey one Wesley and Fabiano
Lanier was also winning but he slipped
and gave away the half point so again
magic number is eight and a half ten
points that will get us our Western
Division championship Archbishop as I
predicted for Dominguez in that round
but the next game his white yes he's
gonna be pressing with white we know
that so let's just say the round two
pairings here for the Archbishop's so
we'll have Fabiano with the white pieces
McKee tarean and then we have Rafael 8ao
with white against restless soul we have
Grandmaster soupy white against Jeffrey
Zhong and we have linear Dominguez
against Andre the amount right so as you
see luckily the logos have been altered
okay so luckily we have carry on Oh
Dominguez Leslie and Jeffrey on our team
the 2700 plus squad the logos yeah yeah
the logos are different but but trust me
we got whoever's the higher seed that's
who we we got the real deal as we say so
let's see anybody that can even upset us
this round so I guess our board three
but our board three is Wesley so yeah
maybe Rafael eight I will try to play
solidly against my sister and try to get
a half a point there but again if we're
giving half a point even at one point in
this match is fine I already have such a
huge lead we just need to get to eight
and a half
and rack up more points after because
once we win the division then we gonna
be first yes it doesn't really matter
how much more points don't buy in the in
the protest League playoffs and we just
join it in the big stakes on the line
we're trying to clinch our Western
Division championship and then a secure
first round bye in the playoffs and then
we'll just need one victory in the
playoffs to get to the Final Four and
wait chess party 2020 is what it's been
made twenty first two to twenty forty
I'm immortal Day weekend Memorial Day
weekend absolutely very very exciting so
after this we'll have a bye and then we
need one more win in a playoff in the
playoffs get to the finals absolutely
should be very exciting easy and good
news for the Chicago wind obviously
Chicago wind has many Webster students
on their team and good news for them
they are beating Argentina two and a
half to one and a half and the only team
that can catch them are the UK lions and
they are currently trailing 3 to 1 so
against California so it's looking like
they will hold on for that fifth spot if
things go their way and they will join
the playoffs so congratulations to them
and team manager Eric Rosen damn alright
so let's take a look do we have moves or
not yes we have to do the same way we're
gonna go today then we go chess TV and
then from here we have to click on the
Archbishop's bar knows the tricks now he
knows the tricks shout-out to national
master Caleb Bettany for teaching or
producer van Simon ok so we're following
Mike we're following GM so Jeffery X
Sebastien which is Dominguez and Fabiano
Caruana
Oh all our team for the archbishop's
that are going to share in the glory of
our Western Division championship let's
check it out starting at the top okay
obviously Fabiano Dominguez Wesley and
Jeffrey airplay but Liam Leigh former
Webster student actually went forward oh
oh one week for us a fantastic
yes very strong player yeah Benjamin
Bach and Nicholas Theodore oh they got
the play of course for Kobe and two-time
world champion and MVP of our summer
series thank you thank you
and obviously before there was the
protest ignores the u.s. chess league
for you were obviously instrumental in
us beating Dallas tell us and in the
gauntlet to to get us the 2014
championship but you were also involved
in other championship championship with
Seattle slugars slugars one year I think
we won in 2013 switched yeah
back-to-back yep alright and we're off
we're off to the game and here we have
we have Wesley so against Grandmaster
late ow
so Leslie chooses the sharp Ruggles in
he's not afraid to to you know he goes
for the sharp rock goes in and let's see
now let's see what's gonna happen so
Wesley is very well prepared in theory
and let how he's already think in Mike
he's trying to figure out what to do
perhaps he is not as as confident in in
this opening so now III was played so
Wesley can jump in with 94 if he wants
to he can also play some flavor his a
publishable t7 ideas yeah so if he just
careful now Queen c2 backed by Rafael a
towel rook e8 rookie ed his idea to
prepare to break with E 5 at some point
so a tree questioning West's Bishop and
now he has to choose what to do either
take on c3 or
we treat with the probably yeah he
decided to take you know simplify the
position a little bit so now so I used
to have a series called forget a
breakdown and one of the things I always
stress was don't block in your bishop
and you see both of these grandmasters
heads so well hopefully Wesley's got the
idea of e52
to release it but I don't know how
White's learned to deal with yeah it's
yeah probably he's gonna say because the
diagonal is already blocked with the
pawn on the tea so he's probably gonna
play before I put the bishop on v2 here
so should we switch to the next game
here so this is a game we have Jeffery
Xiang block against Grandmaster soupy
here and we have a caro-kann defense
sharp caro-kann is played h4 wife is
trying to be very aggressive in Geoffrey
Milton with H wife doesn't want to allow
any space any six so this is interesting
opening here should we have that's very
solid opening choice by Geoffrey again
we we just need to make sure we control
the you know the match we get to the 8th
and half secure the victory and then we
can in a final match we can try to do
well things but otherwise just the most
priority one is right to secure the
eight and half points to get that ten
points to clinch the first place I mean
obviously in all 16 matches today and
we've been heavy favorites in all the
matches but as I tell all the players
just get to that eight and a half we
don't need to run up the score because
we have a perfect season if we have a
perfect season when every game will be
champions and that's exactly what we've
done all seasons
they weren't just one or two close
matches right we were it has some very
close against the Chicago wind Chicago
win give us a lot of trouble one point
yeah you might a lot of trouble Chicago
very yeah but it'd be nice to see them
in the on the final four because they've
they've been one of the elite teams in
the league but they they've always had
to go
us to get to the time of the war and a
lost watch unfortunately they lost both
times to us well they were eliminated on
draw odds one year and then last year we
eliminate them but now they don't have
to go through us they get to the Final
Four but they would have to beat a
couple of strong teams today it's all
slow they'll have to defeat a couple of
strong teams to book those tickets to
actually have to win and maybe Ilya nice
evening the brain so it'd be kind of
cool and they have a romhack opium yes
yes finished third place behind for the
$1,000 blitz for the club yeah yeah that
was a strong tournament yeah yeah for
grandmasters participated in a
tournament Saturday night bar came in
second behind uh Alexander Linderman who
is also on the Chicago yeah Oh Ben Simon
has logged out of his account he must
have been another technical difficulties
okay live we need to login okay it's
just that easy it's just that easy
and with no rating cap this year to
round out who our squad is we also had
some board force on our team that
unfortunately did not get the play this
year because of the no rating cap that
included last year's hero Julian Pro
LICO Josh bloomer dorsa and Niklas
Rosenthal Rosenthal who was instrumental
in helping us win in 2017 yes absolutely
absolutely yeah million port and
Rosenthal were all at the chess house
and then in that overtime win against
Montreal cheers Bravo's you know that
was a close one we had to win 3-1 to tie
the match which we did yes the party and
that propelled us to the championship
against Norway Magnussen they still
couldn't stop us I couldn't
he was on our side after that yeah all
right so back to the games let's see
Dominguez is white against the amount
here and we have another castle in coisa
looks like he's gonna castle there every
round all right so this is six a seven
and he's trying to just block eight and
King be one solid play by dome English
and now I wants to double up the rooks
put pressure on these six maybe play a
four go for it cuz because obviously we
have to leave unfortunately a 2700 home
if we make it to the final four right
because we have to tie them so so
question is who will be right so we have
Fabiano Wesley Geoffrey Fabiano and
Wesley are going for sure gonna freeze
going for sure oh my good it's like who
do you play Dominguez or Leone that's a
good problem to have but the way
Dominguez is going for it today I mean
he's playing some inspiring chests
aggressive transgressive just he once he
wants to make the [ __ ] yeah he's playing
very aggressive definitely look at that
pressure he's putting on it's just
basically completely squeezing the
amount here he cannot play d5 he cannot
play b5 he cannot play a force he cannot
do anything Mike black cannot do
anything it seems like you know he can't
even play a four six more and then start
to play g4 h 4 g5 I mean it's very very
very difficult position here it looks at
the clock look at a clock eight minutes
for Dominguez five for the amount in a
very difficult position here so I don't
know what is Andre going to do very
tough spot he's in Michael let's take a
look maybe at Fabiano's game
Bobby's white and he's playing Mac
Italian and again he is down upon Mike
okay he okay what happened here okay
some sharp long console and medallion is
not backing up - he's pushing so Fabiano
trying to attack here and drop the pawn
on f2 and now he decided to trade coins
and b3 here played by Mickey Torian and
I think this might be a good sign this
is let's see if he can try - okay now
back to equality as far as the past the
pawn structure is ruined for black and
for white as well here I think he will
pay king C to hear Mike just to secure
just to secure but look at the clock
differential here eight in half for
Caruana versus four in half for Mac
Italian II know that's gonna be a factor
far the oldest place fast and that's
gonna be a serious factor in this game
so now I think he will play g4 to secure
the f5 and then he will be able to play
it okay for so he's gonna hopefully hope
for the trade so he can fix those
weakened pawns
interesting so root k fourth you take
Pontic c4 so we'll see
yeah it's probably about equal here
still but I think with the with the
clock situation I like I like our
chances here okay
I like probably animal to win this one
let's look at this so here we have palm
soccer where piece sacrifice has
occurred in a Jeffrey strong game and
this is completely wild here what's
happening here let's take a look
so Bishop g5 more or less solid position
Jeffery played f6 and Grandmaster soupy
sacrifice the bishop and he's goin for
glory here yes threatening 97 so now
three pounds Mike that's huge that is a
strong compensation Queen you have three
thirteen Queen f7 check now Jeffery has
to play the only move and now supey
takes it Bishop e7 and 96 takes now
attacking the knight Jeffery just needs
to get some control some control of the
position here things are very loose here
and soupy 225 and now Jeffrey is behind
on the clock but I think he's got a good
position here Quinn to c6 and if he goes
Queen b3 maybe Queen to c2 just exchange
the Queen yes just exchange the Queen's
oh oh
maybe he can play Queen b6 perhaps okay
Queen c6 is played trying to exchange
the Queen's mic so now if the Queen's
come off the board I like Jeffrey's
chances Queen b6 you know if Queen d5
there might be some repetition here
Queen c6 but Roy's okay drew it's not a
bad result we're up by so much choice
not a better sorry for for against their
board absolutely so so let's take a look
at the next game here Wesley so block
against Rafael 8ao and I like this this
position already he's got a complete
control of the D file and he's yeah he's
got a nice position here so some
exchanges have occurred and and again
the bishop we cannot develop the bishop
that easily you probably have to play
the movie for but then there is a drug
deal goes before his plate yeah probably
might be three yeah yeah and he leaves
it there now Bishop III will play by
Raphael late ow and you know at some
point I think Wesley's and try to play C
5 c4 to cement the position of that
night so Clark's are about equal as well
here so balanced game fairly balanced
here let's take a look at no minions
game he had so much pressure here Wow
what we have here looks like the amount
decided to sacrifice the exchange he
took
politic hmm that's a good question I
think he was worried about the d5 brake
D 5 D for brake he was worried about
so it took with this a for Queen c7 C
for know yeah it's fine I mean he's just
just have to be accurately just trade em
now from now on every trade is gonna
being a linear closer he's got a huge
time advantage on a clock which is a
factor here so he's got extra exchange
as well he's got almost three minutes
more on the clock you just got to figure
out the way to get this night into the
game I'm thinking maybe to play a three
put a rock on c3 and 93 or he decided to
take her HAP's perhaps but now how to
defend the Seaforth on Mike this is the
problem c4 pawn is loose positional
positional I mean it's a knight it's not
our question I don't think he'll do it
but it's not out of question here in a
meantime let's see if Fabiano
how is Fabiana doing he's already
pressing here he's got a dominating
night only for the pawn structure it's
about five pounds each but the knight on
e4 is superior
so now Fabiano can double after rooks to
make sure he's not losing the H con and
then he can go King c4 slowly slowly try
to build up here so I think he's got
good chances here I would go King c4 now
you know some potential to develop
troops as well here like in a rook h2
and Rock DQ
great so you are we gonna get our whoops
fault eh file and order the Jeep at some
point yes at some point but first he
wants to secure the d3 he might even
consider like you know trying to get rid
of the before pawn like it's very hard
to win this position very very hard to
win but if anybody can do it
Fabiano so let's see if anybody can do
it it's gonna be him because he he can
he can figure out he can maneuver
you know this position now maybe b5 I'm
thinking b5 here might get rid of the
weakness you know there's other plans
but but he is pushing he's pushing McKee
tarean here because he's okay now before
here we go back to c4 and now at the
right moment he's gonna double it up
maybe who paid you
maybe Luke h2 maybe one Raquin h2 and
then to some double up on the chief i'll
prepare prepare that he's doing the
other way he doesn't have the a1 square
so I'm just wondering why is he doing it
that way
yeah so he perhaps he wants to put a
roof on g6 b5 played okay okay now this
rookie is gonna start giving some checks
tour Brooksie - he is getting ready to
break in d5 an x-ray at the attack he
should be six by my Italian and now he
wants to go to k4 he wants to get some
activities so has vastly saw his drawn
against Rafael late our slow march these
begun so now we're at four points four
points now 4 to 1 at the moment we're
four and a half points away from
clinching victory and the division
championship so let's take a look now
let's take a look rook d6 is played
Domingues decided to sacrifice the
exchange back I decided that it's easier
for him to play this position then deal
with these two strong bishops and I
think I like this decision - I like this
decision to simplify the position he
will have the control of the D file and
I think he's great news if we do win we
will be a look at that you see how many
people are watching now Ben Simon Ben
Simon we hit are numbered continuing to
broadcast to bring the broadcast of the
people we will be broadcasting our
quarterfinal match up sometime in March
fantastic thing to be determined
fantastic fantastic the numbers are
growing for the audience thank you to
everybody for watching and again this is
a relatively new channel it's a new you
know so it's but it's gonna be it's I'm
sure it's gonna grow and and we
appreciate with our new IT boss Jonathan
runs over the Internet absolutely we've
got a grand
with Jonathan in charge I think it's
gonna grow so big this channel and
competition watch out there and all the
great people at the protest League we're
happy to spread the word right now let's
take a look here the one pair of roots
got swapped here and now I think this is
becoming more clear now what is Fabiana
gonna do he's gonna try to break with
age six and now he's maneuvering his
King to c6 so black cannot move the rook
from h-file because of h6 is coming up
so now the key needy 5 is coming king c6
and i think it's gonna get harder and
harder for SABIC military on to defend
this position it's just getting it done
squeezing it and getting it done and
getting the win here so do you like
Fabiano's chances in the candidates
absolutely that's the next big
tournament they're gonna be happening
and we will be covering this tournament
there will be a commentary for it and
it's gonna be absolutely
Fabiano Carano is the favorite by many
even garry kasparov mentioned him and
England as the the two guys who were
likely to win this so definitely he is a
favorite and we hope to see him do well
and win it again it's hard it's very
hard to win it once but winning
back-to-back it's gonna be very hard but
I think he's in great shape his recent
performance in vacanze there proved it
all right we have some exciting stuff
happening in this board is zu c zu zu p
against Jeffrey strong and things things
are hanging things are messy here
question is time just windows windows
Rendell he's got the move Mike he's got
Luke f7 Lucas 7 he's got night f8 he
plays
my goodness what's happening here he's
under a lot of pressure here but let's
see here perhaps he's hoping for one
inaccuracy from our master Zhu si you
know yeah bricks t5 yeah there we go
night interposes three seconds Jeffrey
Jeffrey it takes it desperation
desperation big check and I don't see a
power oh thanks Oh that'll be me
it's a mate with the pawn can't win one
let's are Jeffrey is our board for
playing against their board too so
there's also a wild one this was a wild
affair here a lot of action a lot of
things so we got soupy soupy whole party
he sacked the peace I don't know if
Jeffrey should have let this happen he
could have had a little bit more solid
approach perhaps but it happened but
let's concentrate on other games let's
see if okay Fabiano is just cruising
here there is no doubt that he's gonna
convert this into a victory here so h 6h
6 yeah he he broke with h6 and yeah swap
the rooks get a passed pawn yeah this is
just no chance here this is gonna be a
pretty easy winner yes this one will be
in the books and now simply King goes to
c6 and now
yeah this is important not to blunder
anything yeah but let's really quickly
switch to the windiest game this is
gonna be a while dominga sustained
diamantes as you can see this game is
over simply c7 and Domingues is bringing
the point home here confidently and and
he wins the game he wins the game and
that gives us another point five to two
at the moment here five to two at the
moment Fabiano is the only one and we
need a full point there as well to feel
safe and secure we would like to clinch
this match with one round to spare yes
that's always a good I know you like
that when you secure a tina one round to
spare so the question is how to win this
position without giving too much counter
play yeah so need a plan need a good
plan here so the question is
oh yeah I feel like this is correct and
yeah and now just just now just king f6
there's a Suk's of anger King f6 puts
him in a soup salon here because now if
the King moves you have e7 checking e6
bishop moves you drop c7 and now he gets
it with the c7 check King e6 unstoppable
mate and that will give us another win
nine of six mate and if Bishop see 397
mate and that puts us in a six points
right there two and a half points away
from clinching division absolutely so
now we are very very close despite
Geoffrey dropping a point in that game
we still managed to win with 25 points
again huge lead here six to two very
very close you know hopefully we can
clinch this in the next round that would
be ideal that would be ideal
looking around the league Chicago wind
is up five to two on Argentina Canada
chess Bros five and a half to two and a
half against he karo and the New York
Marshalls Wow California unicorns led by
former Archbishop Gaudio sure yeah yeah
they're they're cruising against the UK
lion six and a half one and a half and
of course the Archbishop's six the two
against commanding lead with a
commanding lead with two rounds to go
yes yes let's see who is our best
performance so far let's take a look so
we have looks like Fabiana won his both
games Domingues has won in half Wesley
has won in had that Street Jeffery has
won so Viviano Caruana
perfect score so far between - I mean
you know he's got the candidates coming
up as we mentioned and his training his
training and if anybody he plays he
plays the commitment committee we played
ever every game last year and six of the
seven this year so hands heads off to
Bob you know
in our quarterfinal match but the final
patch yes that's gonna be right before
the candidates hopefully and then finals
after the candidates hoping therefore
that absolutely yes here we have it and
logos have been changed logos have been
changed as you see Wesley drew Jeffery
unfortunately dropped a point there it
was a wild game but we have Fabiano
coming through and linear Domingues
securing the twin half points in this
match and with a huge lead 6 to 2
we are hoping that we're gonna clinch
the victory and division in the next
round and round number three absolutely
very very exciting you know games and I
think we can start in a couple of more
minutes maybe maybe there's a there's a
live game going on not camp with another
game the protest League
yeah or we can we can we can take a look
at this looks like it's all it looks
like it's all all settled
Chicago's up 6 to Canada now five and a
half two and a half against New York
that's a big Fork yeah that's a big
score especially especially in the
standings we will be right back in three
minutes to unveil round three the st.
Louis chess club hosts the 2020 US
Championship and US Women's Championship
April 8th through the 25th these
national championship events feature 12
of the strongest chess players in
America
competitors will battle for a combined
prize fund of nearly $300,000
qualification into the world
championship cycle and the coveted title
of US Champion first round of play
begins April 10th at the st. Louis chess
club watch live at the club or at us
chess champ
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back to week seven of the approach s
League I am the manager of the st. Louis
Archbishop's michael comer and one side
me Grandmaster bar a Hoban everybody we
are currently up six two at halftime
against Brazil if we win of course we
will clinch the Western Division
championship securing a first round bye
in the protest League playoffs and we'll
just need one win to get to Oslo Norway
May 21st through the 24th in the Final
Four so hopefully we can do it and we
got pairings for round three pairings
are coming up and with the correct
graphic so write our board one Fabiano
against their board - who actually won a
game last round
sooo participate and then we got board
our board or two Domingues
against their number one seed rally
towel and now we have Jeffrey Zhong our
board for playing their board three
McCallum and then oh they used to be
teammates they know each other yes the
amount against Wesley so again we're
heavy favorites in all the matches but
this is the wrong way we really need to
get the twin half points to secure yes a
match victory so if we get eight and a
half we'll secure an extra ten bonus
points and then we'll be the champions
because Canada cannot catch us as long
as we win today and we had a win because
then we'll be the champions so it's very
important that we win and the game
should beginning and momentarily and
again this is all for the qualification
of the finals for finals will be in in
May yeah Oslo Norway it'll be just Party
2020 they bill it magnus carlsen will be
there win lose or draw
Fabiano and Wesley will also be there
hammer and all that just that commentary
lies I'm sure Danny will be there both
tears and a Rudolph I'll be there and
hopefully I'll be there maybe the whole
team can go alright yeah
harder a whole plane down great reward
to the season yes so book your tickets
now it's gonna be it's gonna be a blast
it looks like Canada chest bras like the
chest for us we'll be down there that
was very exciting last year we got to go
to a San Francisco back-to-back years
actually we've got to go to San
Francisco but last year's it was even
more fun because we won obviously we got
the gold medal and but a lot of fans of
the chest bras were there too and they
kind of adopted us as the team and there
was a lot of fun but Bobby had a crew a
cheering crew - Kristen sure Ella
Alejandro Ramirez were down there
cheering them on and awesome it was a
lot of fun
and we won everyone we've got the Browns
on luckily wet yeah we got the Browns
list you're in 2018 we were dominant but
we couldn't get our top players as Caleb
Denby says I don't leave home without
World Championship gold medal it happens
yes that was a lot of fun last year and
hopefully uh back to back back to back
camp but as I said our expectations for
the season we're just one thing just get
to the Final Four because the Final Four
is a totally different animal it's live
chest yeah yeah if you haven't been down
there if you weren't lucky enough to go
to San Francisco the last couple years
this is live chest
they're playing on the computer but
they're like face it off at the same
table or on their computer and they're
wearing these nor is canceling
headphones so the spectators it's unlike
any chess event you've ever been to
forgot to play to an 18 and it's a lot
of fun you there's a big like movie
screens that show the alive
on the board and you can cheer you can
boo you can laugh at their moves a
Julian played some speculative moves on
that day one and it was like he got to
be the hero yeah he a hero and he got
the game clinching win against the baden
baden baden baden yeah Bob and Bob and
somehow made it and they won right yeah
yeah by the part in the ad they got a
huge upset against the the Panda honda's
how they beat pandas if it went to
overtime and luckily because we were a
little late for that match all right but
as I ramble on as a pest boy we've got
glory on the board Colonel Lawrence we
are occurring chlorine as Domingues
white against Lake Tahoe and we have a
chichi Liam's sharp Sicilian defense so
let's see now
dough Magus has been been playing a
aggressive chest today so he's been long
castling long can let's see let's see if
it's gonna repeat now let's see I think
he's getting ready he's getting ready to
come on Castle is open I feel like he
wants to come on Castle again yeah it's
a very very exciting so let's see here
oh yeah welcome to the the holiday
holiday weekend Presidents Day I invite
your friends to join the stream join the
chat have some fun and hello to a Peter
and Duncan thanks for watching
alright let's take a look at this game
so again supey is dangerous we saw that
soupy he won a game so in Fabiano he's
playing a sharp sitting is Fabiana and
Fabiana decided it's time to attack and
push the h-bomb let's go and we should
be 7 by soupy the question is if
fabiana's in a go h5s well here oh he's
there or he's gonna play Bishop e2 and
g4 some different kind of approach
scheana so Bishop g5 Queen d3 and I can
see he's gonna castle is open if you
don't know what you're doing I do not
advise this for players that are
non-experts
it's really sharp so you gotta make sure
you put your King on b1 to the safety
but yeah sharp stuff but spawn stuff
supposed to be fun and and Brazil has
nothing to lose absolutely nothing to
lose for them and if they're playing
also strongest teams in the league and
they want to show the best steak and
Cape all right unlike in previous years
there's no like relegation so if you
finished like last you're not going to
be relegated to to do the play and again
your bills in the league it's the same
way is it gonna be they're gonna be more
teams at it or what's what they're
trying to do who knows they do a wrinkle
every every year like in this year there
while they reduce the time control from
game 15 who's game 10 the gamepad plus
new second increment and they got rid of
the rating the rating camp yeah you know
sky's the limit
you never know what what Danny wrench
and all the gray
everyone's the League have in mind for
next year hopefully we'll get bigger and
better and uh alright let's take a look
at Jeffrey Jean game into his block and
he's playing faster
that's very good already yeah playing
faster he's not falling behind on a
clock and and he's playing more solid
yes which is good too so as Jeffrey
drunk believer mad is our board for at
2700 plus but his pairings get easier as
the yes the game goes he starts against
their top two boards now he's playing
yeah so he is black against Mickey
tarean here and he's got two minutes
advantage on the clock already and he's
got pressure on us before us well my
candy forest hanging - it's looking like
English safe no sorry the previous game
I didn't like it that much because I
think he allowed too much you know the
the solid the solidity wasn't there in
that game and then it back kind of
backfired so we dropped the point but
it's fine yeah but now we are pressing
we're pressing and Geoffrey's pressing
care only for on c4 pieces are well
developed McDaniel is slightly
uncomfortable already already now you
know probably 92 would be the move to
secure both pants and then a six
preparing Samba firebreak perhaps so we
like absolutely and then we have Vesely
so he's playing with the block pieces
against his former teammate from Webster
Andre the amount and so we have looks
like an English defense and Andre I went
for the break and Wesley tried to lock
the position they got some space
advantage
I like his position I like the space I
like this Bishop is being shot down on
g2 not so clear house didn't come into
the game so I like it I really like what
what West is doing so far he's got a
very very good control of the position
they should be for the amount gives the
bishop and now Leslie has the control of
the two bishops which is an advantage as
well I'm not sure about this last
decision will be revolution city square
is weakened as well here
I don't know he was worried but C 3
square is weakened as well here so I
like I like this position for Leslie
very much now and so we looked at
Jeffery and let's go back Domingues and
of course he did it again
he did it again third game in a row
Domingues castles long and of course
King b1 because black was threatening a
very tricky Bishop g5 to win the Queen
but of course domain this is a safety he
is taking a lot of chances I have to say
he must got the memo like if you want to
want to go to the Final Four no more
quick easy draws so I guess you should
play Bishop e2 and they try to prepare
some g 4h for g5 ideas you know
something like that be sure to play and
they're going G for H 45 and press and
press
so this is kind of ideas that I would
consider for him in this position he is
two minutes behind on the clock so he
needs to speed it up a little bit here
and try to put the pressure on Laketown
be a 2727 Castle c5 it's it's possible
but also at the same time it weakens the
d5 score so it needs to be more careful
yeah perhaps we should be six on this if
I said Bishop c5 Wow look at da Mo's
Bishop e7 perhaps Bishop e7 right
perhaps there should be seven but then
he can just play something like this
should be too interesting so yeah he can
just play Bishop e2
I mean he can repeat of course also I
don't think I don't know he's gonna
repeat I don't think he's gonna try to
make a draw with the white pieces all
right yeah should be two there we go
and now I think black should Castle
black should castle and there is a
tactic of Queen takes e5 but then black
takes D takes e5 okay you don't want any
of that so if the Queen c7 Queen side
actually castles and now now it's time
for the the pawn pushes on the Kings
side it looks like Domingues g4 or h4
which one you got there well I think
writing with g4 is interesting g4 h
water but it's very sharp door I mean
it's kind of double-edged because I
could say the B file is open there is
some potential for bloc to organize the
attack there as well so let's take a
look at another game
while we're waiting on this one Fabiano
against swoopy alright so please squeeze
came off the board here interesting so
you think about this variant I had a
really cool name for it but I forgot
what it is so as you see in a couple of
these games we're casting on the
opposite side so so so I devised the
game I haven't actually played it yet
but you have to Castle you can't castle
on the same side as your opponent so so
like if I Castle kingside you can either
keep your king in the center
all classical our Castle queenside are
manually castle you know get your king
over there but I mean it as you see it
it's a whole different element to the
chess games where you get more decisive
results but I think it might be too much
of an advantage for white because you
can just play you know so you know if
you're bored and one played chess
variant try that one again 92 and now f4
so of course my Briana wants to put the
policy but supy doesn't himself to get
that f4 square for the rook now g5 and
it's not so simple
how about rook t3 Brooke h3 and hit that
pawn
yeah well that's probably what he's
going to do ya know you know we might
lose on g5 there but but I think that's
probably what's gonna happen here
because black wants to take take and put
a bishop on a4 to create his own his own
counter play maybe in the world will
come up with absolutely we have Jeffery
strong here in a commanding position
here extra powerful
Jeffery he's got I think he outplayed it
his opponent here he is opponent to
qualify remember we were thinking here
and Jeffery played b5 breaking open the
position here takes by the way if you
take what upon the 94 was very powerful
so he took and now he goes there should
be six
and now the bishop is under attack but
he can play something like Queen b7 and
attacking the pawn on g2 so it should be
a no problem here for Geoffrey to
convert his arc upon Wow
crushing victory by Vesely so here's let
you see how it happened so after a three
but we question the bishop before
decision it looks like a dubious
decision giving bishop arrested two
bishops and you know what this they will
do when he has to be here it will open
up the position
look at that move c5 opening up the
position the amount cannot take the
knight is hanging and now let's they
just open it up now black block is just
winning here Queen b6 and the amount
resigns because if he takes vesta gotta
go Knight c3 Queen d2 and a fantastic
tactical 2492 check
it's only a pawn but it's just a
hopeless position and the amount threw
in the towel and that gives archbishop 7
points 1/2 points away from a perfect
regular season title yeah absolutely
absolutely fantastic play by Wesley - in
half out of three - in half he's been
very stable he has been very stable
throughout the whole season
yes of course he was welcome MVP with
you in 2017 you know he like almost
never even lost the game it was
fantastic many four no performances
leading the way in 2017 world
championship and then we and of course
the summer summer serious as well so
this is the game of late tau domine Deus
and late our three and a half minutes
for domine Deus and 4 and 4s 47 for late
ow and still a struggle still a struggle
here
and Dominguez has good development but
not a easy way to break through not a
concrete plan here Mike what do you
think not a concrete way to do anything
here perhaps maybe he need to put a look
back on f1 and sacrifice 106 to damage
that structure maybe of cooking a chain
and then take on everything you know to
open up the position to expose that King
yeah black probably wants to play c4
[Music]
there's a possibility of dropping the
bishop back only 7 if you play rock f1
so there there is an idea there as well
so so Knight c3 play by Domingues aiming
to put a knight on d5 but I expect
before I anticipate c4 here flown late
ow
very sharp very sharp very sharp here
let's see what Fabiano came up with so
they swapped everything and now he has
the nice advantage here so and the swap
has occurred and they're trading crooks
so this is a clear advantage and he's
right on time to stop block from playing
the move d5 and fixing those weaknesses
with c4 and this is a I think a nice
advantage for Fabiano maybe with a
perfect play Grandmaster you know supey
can hold on you know but it's not so
easy so I I expect Fabiano to try to
press this very hard and try to get
point the victory to get the match
clincher
absolutely so again we need 18 1/2 we're
at 7 right now so we need one and a half
points
out of the remaining three games and
seal the deal and this is why these
games are being played over on on chest
comm you
follow all the games live if you know
the trick or you can just follow these
guys and watch the games live as well
and of course chest comm / TV I'm sure
Danny wrench is on there no fantastic
fantastic
thank you guys yeah so the point is to
go Bishop d1 I think then Lin linear
wants to go Bishop d1 and if capture is
occurred um b3 ones take back with a
bishop on betrayed nice you know so
there should be solid he wants to remain
solid so yeah the clock the clock is the
issue he's a little bit behind on the
clock but I think his position is fine
so let's take a look now so we looked at
Fabiano and then what about Jeffrey
Jeffrey something has happened something
has happened and he something has
happened here somehow he could not
consolidate and
now okay if you allow the swap of the
roof so he he correctly that doesn't
want to allow that so this is block is
up upon I feel like with the time
situation I'm putting money on the best
on Jeffrey two windows because with the
clock situation okay yeah so yeah if
they had like an hour on the clock yet
draw is probably more likely but here's
big factor here huge factor I would say
and Wesley already won his game so now
we just need to in half points one in
half points minimum from these three
remaining games to secure the match
victory
okay okay five here's the main guess is
trying to force this capture so he can
finally put that Bishop on d3 in that
good position here and that happens here
so what can he do here this block real
sacrifice does block have a trick does
block have something interesting h6
solid move but unclear if it
accomplishes great defenders yeah so I
was watching the clearance Cup broadcast
and Alejandro Ramirez was filling in for
Maurice it looked like and he had a very
interesting comment your take on it like
you see how these bishops are great is
they common knowledge he said that the
rooks are the worst offenders in chess
that's really in certain positions in
certain positions yeah in certain
positions you know like like if you have
a passed pawn the best piece to block
the pass pawn is the night yes so it
really depends if you if you're
defending a routine game you have to put
your look behind it so there are
different concepts in really different
positions so look before played now
attacking the pawn on e4 and the
question is what to do
how to defend this pawn here not so easy
with clock ticking down here anything
can happen in this game it's do not want
to play Queen to e3 there's a queen to
e1 this is way different than Queen
protects it protects in attacks but late
how can double up to be coming up with
potential sacrifice on behaviour to
expose the position of Lanier's King I
like just to keep it safe yes okay let's
see here so c4 is played before and now
Fabiana is marching his King in it's a
big March and now King goes to b5 Bishop
e3 attacking the knight wow this is this
is really wild here Mike really really
wild here you'll have pastors this epon
is going Fabiana pushes his pawn king c
to play by Zeus e and now what to do
here c5 he plays really work though c5
is played and it instantly played takes
takes and now probably king b2 will be
played here but there's a 93 chick
picking up the e5 hub again it's closely
I guess I guess you couldn't take the
knight no you didn't have anything
married he couldn't do anything better
so that's why he had to go for it and
that's it well no it's not that's it yet
but it's gonna be very hard to push the
pawn so I think this my end in a draw
but you know supey has only 14 seconds
on the clock and Fabiano has two minutes
so they may be easy they go maybe he is
forcing errors maybe he can force an
arrow
he's going for the fork but this Jerry
it's a fork this this is when the two
second increment really comes into play
yeah you can't really fly you cannot
take it because if you're taking a
five-plus yeah it's just it looks like
soupy soupy is turning to be their hero
of this matter the guy who scores points
for them yeah the computer will just
call it but if it finds a three-fold
repetition let's go back to the linear
really quickly to see what has just
happened here so a lot of exchanges has
occurred which i think is good for
linear here should be a row should be a
draw but you know it's very hard to push
this a pond that's the problem
it's very hard to push off anybody has a
chance it's linear it's linear if
anybody has chance it's definitely him
Bobby dude there was no plan seven in
half that's a one point one point we
need one point from the remaining two
games to win the division
Jeffrey every can be the board for here
Oh Jeffrey can't do it he's up two
pounds Mike can he bring it home here
the opposite oh yes opposite colors
danger zone under ten seconds but still
I think he's got some chances there is
some potential Sebastian Domingues rules
so eight point eight points now all we
need is another half a point so Jeffrey
can get the draw and you can secure the
Western Division and it looks like it's
gonna be a draw after all here through
one check don't take chances take
chances Jeffrey draw is fine drunk is
fine take it
secure it yeah oh here we go there's a
pig
secure it Bishop takes pawn Bishop takes
pawn 2020 Western Division champions of
the pros congratulations thank you sir
congratulations that you was excellent
excellent job Mike
congratulations they're all are 14
teammates it's been a heck of a ride
perfect season it's tough to do we have
secured a first round bye in the
playoffs which is huge huge and we will
be playing the quarterfinal match
against either the Eastern Division
champion or the Central Division
champion their their third-place team
that's who's going to go ahead and head
in the first round and then we'll be
waiting for them and then if we win that
one we'll be on the way to Norway in May
21st through the 24th book your tickets
now it's gonna be a heck of an
experience chess party 2020 also when we
have the video can we play the video
please Ben Simon so this is hit Norway
the chess capital of Europe being Greek
and Seibel with Magnus Carlsen
it's the protest League finals at chess
party 2020 Caruana so
photos camera Rudolph chess bras an open
Fischer random chess tournament
[Music]
will you be part of the world's biggest
chess party
all right so you look out one that's
gonna be we were lucky enough to go to
San Francisco the last two years and
bring home the gold medal last year
check it out
and anyhow it is a fan experience a
total fan experience I mean the players
are live at the venue and it's a much
more casual atmosphere where fans can
come up to players like bar Cobian shake
their hand get an autograph and have a
lot of fun and the players when they're
playing will be wearing noise canceling
headphones so you can sit there and
actually cheer and kibitz with your
friends point out the moves on the big
screen and listen to the live commentary
on last year was Danny ranch Robert Hess
all the awesome guys that do a great job
at chess calm and it's a lot of fun but
Commissioner Gregg Sahadi will be there
most likely as well and chess stars like
the Montreal chess pros Viviano Wesley
and the world champions the current
champion
hopefully that will all change come
November the first Americans Bobby
Fischer as the world champion that would
be a st. Louis resident Bobby I know
carry on old and probably I don't carry
on real American by the way a lot of
people a lot of people like to say that
he's not he was born in Florida so yeah
that means on the holiday Presidents Day
weekend so that we maybe you'll get to
go to the White House right all right
let's get the results these are the
results Mike oh right well check out the
results so eight and a half that's all
it takes
we got the perfect season we got the
Western Division championship so we
don't even have to we can just all offer
draws or or resign on move one I guess
for this round because we did it we did
it and all right so that mean does that
mean break time Bensimon alright well
we'll be back with the conclusion if you
what I mean we already clinched it but
just see how they do and I have some fun
this is a protest League is that you mr.
Mimi we get your autograph yeah of
course I think it's pretty cool that you
love chess so much we love just to enjoy
school chess program and gotta meet a
real-life Grandmaster I had this big one
time I put a police captain after school
and checkmate in a min 27 moves wow I
should be asking for your autograph
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis Chess Club org Norway the chess
capital of Europe Miri and Seibel with
Magnus Carlsen it's the pro chess league
finals at chess party 2020 Caruana
so
boat s hammer Rudolph chess bras an open
Fischer random chess tournament
[Music]
will you be part of the world's biggest
chess party
the st. Louis chess club hosts the 2020
US Championship and US Women's
Championship April 8th through the 25th
these national championship events
feature 12 of the strongest chess
players in America competitors will
battle for a combined prize fund of
nearly $300,000 qualification into the
world championship cycle and the coveted
title of US Champion first round to play
begins April 10th at the st. Louis chess
club watch live at the club or at u.s.
Chess Champion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back after a short break and
we already won today's match yes secured
eight eight and half eight and a half
points already and that's what it takes
to get to get the win and we got the
perfect season the perfect regular
season we are now the Western Division
champions of the probe chess league that
st. Louis Archbishop's so
congratulations to our entire -
congratulations everybody
yeah all the guys and but we still have
couple of more matches we ran up the
score yeah so it would be nice to finish
with a big win this match
round four to get some extra extra
points as well and that will you know be
more confidence a little bit for the
upcoming playoffs right yeah especially
a Jeffrey Zhang going up against the
board for cuz he'll be uh he'll be
playing in the playoffs
Jeffrey Jang will be in our quarterfinal
matchup so it'd be nice to get him
rolling wide against the amount yeah he
hadn't had the best day Jeffrey so he's
had 50% right now right c11 he lost one
and Ramon so be nice to finish on a
plastic or everybody else had a really
strong day just so far but he did get
the match clincher draw exactly it's a
pleasure fakes finally eliminated in the
last pop solutely like that so we're
about to see the next game okay yeah so
these are the matchups it's all it's
board one against board one board two
against four two and so forth so Fabiano
and Dominguez will have black against
their counterparts and Wesley so white
against Mac Italian and Jeffrey white
against the amount yes so we expect
Jeffrey to try to press in this game and
hopefully get a win yes we'll put him
two and a half points so would be nice
to nice to win big in this one yeah this
is when where are the the biggest
favorites too as though as the match
gets further along this is when we have
the rating difference is more visible
yes and it's really nice how how
rasli so as our board three has an
opposite color of Wesley in the last
I think that that's an underestimated
advantage that we have because Wesley is
our abort three actually
yeah Wesley is our board three omegas
has the braiding supplement they use
Domingues
out raided them by like a pointer at
home so that's you can't really stack
against them they basically they you
have to put in my rating order yes yes
whether whatever the December supplement
was in 2019 that's that's already used
for the entire year and you have to put
them in order and that's how I'm gonna
be the playoffs the finals and
everything yes yes absolutely so so that
you can't really like if they if the
other guy holds with black the other guy
can win with white and it's really a
nice luxury to have absolutely
absolutely so the games way and looks
like the chess Browns were we need right
the chess board yeah let's let's check
out the need a win the other the other
matches going on we're not the only game
going on right now there there are every
Western Division team is is playing so
oh yeah New York making a little bit of
a comeback they were down by a huge
margin and now their New York is
trailing Canada six and a half five and
a half that's huge because on they were
playing for a second place right now and
obviously New York Queens
yeah they will get the second place
right yeah right yeah there's New York
wins they adela don't have a chance
New York yeah New York is trailing can
about going into that game by about 11
points but but once New York wins if
they win they'll get that time and in
the point and the point so most likely
if if New York wins this match they
might finish second yeah finishing
higher will give them it would give them
an advantage yes so so that there we go
yeah graphics they're signing matchup
coming up and then let's see just and it
looks like the Chicago wind
have clinched a playoff berth they win
because it looks like it looks like
there it looks like UK cannot catch them
so congratulations the Chicago
they have many Webster players on their
squad and they're led by Eric Rosen who
manager is Eric our friend Eric Ross yes
yes yes all right do we have some moves
here yes sir yes sir okay so let's see
here they're waiting for moves so
they're the last round should be getting
underway and we have the moves now the
game is just started so Rafael a towel
against Fabiano Carwin oh let's see what
Fabiano gonna do Bobby yeah MVP of last
year and he's doing great again this
year led the team to a perfect season
what more could you ask for it right yep
d5 now and the question is is it gonna
play which move here is in and go for
Bishop before rut goes in you know he's
done we still meet the client solid
opening choice qgd
yeah so with with the pressure off I
mean yeah they should still play solidly
and you know and get some chances so
let's see here
soupy played efore endo mean gets opens
up with Chilean are we gonna see if the
fourth long cast my prediction is he is
not going to cancel for inside this game
it looks like it's it's impossible now
break then we have Restless so with the
white pieces against Mickey Torian so a
c6 is played so Bradley Bishop a4 again
Wesley is heavy favorite with the white
pieces in this game oh I will see how he
would do and we have Jeffery who
three-and-oh today right it's gotten I
think he may be right
- yeah I don't think we have anybody
with perfect scores today but we have
some guys we can finish with three and
half like Wesley like Bobby that's team
another team efforts absolutely yeah you
know it's it's rather to have a balanced
team that have somebody win 4-0 in my
opinion yeah more balanced him yes with
the rating cap with no rating cap this
year in the protest League we are able
to play all 27 hundreds pretty much
weekend and we in the previous years we
could only do two right we had two
monsters than a solid 2500 and then an
underrated board for such as bloomer
Julian Nicholas Rosa Rosa Tom yeah even
Spencer Lehmann got to play wouldn't you
be a master Spencer women shout out to
him so now the question is if black can
do something like 95 or yeah to simplify
the position 94 95 but there that could
be taken and then rookie 1 so it's yeah
it's playable so on Sunday February 23rd
Spencer Lehman and and maybe a JJ Ali
Marathi or on the there'll be a group of
eight playing an event called decisive
chess so get this
so each player start
with 60 minutes with a five-second delay
if at any time they agree to a draw aha
okay they flip the board and start with
the opposite color and their remaining
time hock time and then they play until
there is a decisive winner and then you
know if you draw again
same thing you flip the board back and
then but the time remains the same so
whatever balance you have all the time
that's all you have on move isn't this
just an idea of a custom drummel idea I
believe so Simon confirmed yeah so we're
gonna test that out on Sunday February
20 how many players were gonna playing
eight just just eight players will have
some grandmasters I am Sandow how many
rounds four rounds it's gonna be a long
day especially if there's some draws
draw they flipped it played with the
remaining time yes still there is your
answer and so somebody you know
checkmates or flags or but there's a
delay ya know away from it that's very
important very important yeah Tony rich
are an executive director he's got some
good ideas and yeah he said no we're
doing delay so that way you can't just
amass time yeah you know quick perfect
you can never add time all right so
Bishop g4 is played so so in this
position bishops before and probably
going to see something like rook a d1
played by Geoffrey putting some more
pressure on d6 I like his position here
and again he's playing faster so that's
good so let's take a look at Fabiano's
game against late ow so a lot of
liquidation here okay so there was some
took the bishop so we have we should be
seven coming up Knight takes f6 Queen f6
yeah I don't think White has anything
here
Aviano is very comfortable you know Axl
this position so he's absolutely
comfortable here so 95 so I don't see
any any problems here for example Knight
f6 Queen f6 if you're gonna go 97 I will
take on a 430 made here and threatened
to win your Bishop so I really don't
know how white is going to proceed here
absolutely quality let's look at
Sebastian Dominguez game he has a
one-game one out of 48 refer to normal
right look at his opponent
this is superior member oh yeah the
dangerous soupy so he scored some points
so before Lanier is going after the
night and trying to push again we have
already win won the match we got eight
and a half points already but we would
like to get another win in this match
okay back up some more point night is
gonna go probably on d5 yeah
because putting the knight on the rim
wouldn't be a good idea so that's why
nycos on d5 I guess it would be nice
it looks like Armenia has a hundred and
forty four points so we currently have
134 and a half points plus or eight and
a half points I'm not very good at math
as you can tell 124 and a half plus ten
plus eight and a half leaves us with 143
so we are currently one point behind
Armenia I don't know what that really
matters I mean you already play their
match sure it'd be crazy to think that
they have 144 and just six matches
though they must have no I don't know
when they played it but they must have
played it with some sharp development
here in a game Domingues supey here
and linear is attacking on c2 and a lot
of fireworks here the heart of fire was
not an soupy Wow soupy retreats superior
treats and that's a very good sign here
that's a very very good sign he retreat
center if so it looks like if my
calculations are correct we will play
the winner in the quarterfinals against
India versus Norway and you know Norway
will be bringing their best effort
because the championship is in Norway so
it might be a exciting mattress I'll
probably be cheering for India against
Norway in that first round matchup and
India seems to be on a losing streak as
well a loose they lost to Armenia or not
no they lost to Armenia ten and a half
five and nine today yes and they lost
the Russia Wizards ten to six the final
week so wow so they'll be they'll be
playing Norway that's near with a
serious advantage already against
McEachern serious advantage on the board
serious advantage on the clock as well
so e5 is loose so real real pressure
hello
oh and look who Norway has they got him
from last year our board for Hiro from
last year he was on the a-team han smoke
Niemann play he's their secret weapon
down there and Norway is on a terror
after losing their first two matches
win-win-win-win-win and they crushed the
Raptors twelve and a half to three and a
half so they're on a mission they want
to get that ticket to the finals all
right
I mean they're already there and they'll
have a massive home-field advantage yet
all the cheering crowd yeah all the
funds so while so it will be Norway
against India and then and then we'll
play us in that in that quarterfinal
matchup and they're on a mission so this
will be a very nothing is nothing is a
sure thing in that chess or in life
absolutely
well huge advantage we have to say for
Leslie here and Geoffrey is playing
Whitey's up upon against Diamant and
just kind of drawing so I don't know
he's up upon here I'd like to see him
win Mike I'd like to see him press and
win a game here but it's not easy
because you know the amount is just down
upon but it's very active rook so I
don't know what he will want to do here
how is it thinking about this so
Geoffrey has the white pieces the bomb
but yeah yeah as you can see here there
were a lot of liquidations and he
decided to go rogue d3 defense from this
angle so I guess he wants to play a four
maybe put the rook on f3 and start
walking the King to C pawn perhaps this
is what he wants to do not not afford
King cheating okay so the rook would
defend the island so assuming you play a
four king of six I put the King on his
six I might even play a five myself to
cement the position very interesting
yeah
all right so advantage we have advantage
on this board we reversely in a big
advantage as well let's go back to
Fabiano see how things are developing
there
his opponent Rafael a cow is playing
very aggressive but be speculative a
chess here is basically throwing the
kitchen sink but you're not gonna just
come and meet four beyond okay just not
gonna work in I think we're about to see
a resignation very soon it's everything
is hanging the attack is going nowhere
Mike and Fabiana looks like gonna score
three and a half points for us today
yeah just-just-just there's nothing f4
is dropping the bishop on c4 is loose
there's just nothing gonna happen so it
looks like it's gonna be a win before
Fabiano here and the meantime domine
guess he's up a pawn he's up a foul
against soupy and Knight of 6 is played
perhaps his opponent can capture the
pawn back on a6 but that might be also a
little poison plum because who can come
to aid and create some treasure as well
so he took on before I wonder if there
was a way if there was a way to keep the
pawns I wonder if like a move like a 5
for example could have been played here
you know just take secure but you didn't
want that so 7 I like black black is
still better there's a pressure on c2
here so I like black here it's good for
the archbishop so far so far yeah
and let's see yeah Wesley so played 93
he's trying to get rid of the strong
black a derp here yeah and this is
definitely a very very strong position
for him three minutes for me catarrian
and five in half for Wesley so yeah it's
a clear advantage here and if it takes
we can take back with the H pawn big
meeting big meeting and they are
let's go production room okay 93 and if
capture is only three you can take back
with a pawn and now you open up the F
file you have pressure on f7 and Queen
h5 is coming up as well so 93 pawn takes
c3 Bishop g3 pawn takes g3 and you have
Queen h5 coming up as well putting a lot
of pressure on f7 and h6 so I think this
is a very very nice advantage here for
Wesley here executive director turning
riches in the house so it's always good
to see Tony
now we're gonna charter a plane to
Norway if we get there he says maybe ok
unfortunately okay okay looks like
Fabiano won already actually his game
alrighty I know with another win yeah so
yeah after root before we thought it was
already over so Luke before putting
pressure on c4 and f4 and Bishop d3
played and now he just played aged six
and there are no more threats now f4
pawn is hanging and now he's opponent
just resigned he also had one minute on
a clock so the game is over and now we
have nine and a half points already it
seems like I am gonna take your position
for and we will we will
okay all right perfect okay all the way
we already won the division so nothing
left to say anyway yes
all right so you got Mike comer this is
1700 Missouri 1998 Missouri scholastic
state champion doing the analysis so
points in a grading at least but here we
go
Oh Mingus is on the move will he trade
the Queens Domingues playing the black
pieces we'll see if there's a big Queen
trade on the board Oh
his opponent supey says no way I'm
playing to win the game okay well you
should have traded cuz we're take c2 is
on the board it's like now what are you
gonna do there are tactics everywhere
gumming up and let's see what she's got
going on Rick take c2 but his rook is a
defended three ways by the king the
bishop and his counterpart the other
room soupy you sure the traded Queens
when you had the chance he's really
regretting that now oh and he he remote
well the knight is also defending the
rook but why why would you voluntarily
remove a defender so Kings are the worst
offenders in chess as obviously you see
here the King just wants to uh save
himself it's like I'm out of here rook
you're on your own buddy and now
Dominguez he says hey you want to trade
again and this time he'll have no choice
you should have taken him when you had
the first opportunity unless he's gonna
really retreat the e1 but I do not see
that happening so Dominguez is playing
if you've been following the protest
League Dominguez was really just content
with just drawing as the black pieces a
lot of berlin's not this week he says
I'm taking it to you guys and really
playing some aggressive chess and really
doing a well there there goes the Queen
back to e1 let's see maybe maybe maybe
Oh Domingues will
Queen to e2 forcing the Queen trade
unless the Queen wants to retreat to be
one very interesting very interesting
he's doing a little dance with the
Queen's and why why does soupy I guess I
guess with those two pawns the two
passed pawns
I guess soupy cannot trade the Queen's
we have club manager Ryan Chester in the
house you might remember him from the
blunder series this the Saturday morning
cartoon type show that was a great show
for Saturday morning the blunders very
very good and of course don't get forked
if you want to have a good laugh Google
Perry Coulson don't get for it that's uh
that's a very very exciting one and of
course I am on don't get forth and I'm
happy to say I did not believe it or not
because I knew bishops can move
backwards a lot of people when they're
do not get that that bishops can move
backwards to help defend somehow someway
but it's a very good resource all right
and then if you're if you want a Yasir
style show big fan everybody's a big fan
of Yasser he actually comment eights on
some of the chests bras streams Ryan
Chester had a show called
between two ponds which is apparently a
pun fun that I do not understand well
while I plug it all a Ryan Chester's
great shows I might as well plug some of
my own to begin her breakdown and of
course the Blitz bounty if you want
another good laugh after watching Perry
Coulson don't forget pork you can google
blitz bounty gangsta audition I'm in
Forest Park playing a club regular
on behalf of our good friend Mario Roper
he's in the video as well
and watch out for a cameo from Jonathan
shrines in that in that Edition as well
all right back to the games he did
actually put his Queen on b1 I mean what
is this guy up to so this is not a soupy
zest effort today he is just getting
clobbered by a domain guys so let's go
Oh Wesley Sousa ponent is in the danger
zone it only has six point seven seconds
left under that 10 seconds but it is a
bishop of options to color and game so
anything can happen maybe you can make
some simple moves and math some time
Wesley so is playing with the white
pieces and has to pass pawns and that
should be enough compensation even
though you know bishop opposite color
and he's very tough to win but we'll see
we'll see yeah there go the pawns here
comes another pawn push just keep
pushing him keep pushing him no reason
no reason right not to play d5 he's not
afraid of that check he's not afraid of
rook the g1 check that is not checkmate
so okay so he's gonna get the a pawn
orange go for the h-bond okay Oh Bishop
g2 Bishop g2 all right aren't just king
up white is winning oh there goes d6
yeah push the furthest pawned d7 d 7re
protects the pawn he's not worried about
taking that Jeep on that has nothing to
do with anything now and sure enough
he's like Mike you don't know what
you're talking about I'm taking the Jeep
but now he gets checked I told you oh
alright alright and it's over white won
by resignation so now we have ten and a
half points and we're coming up
I think we have just as many points as
Armenia now I said I don't think it even
matters but it's just good for bragging
rights we have the most points in the
fruit juice and of course we got the
perfect seven and OH season which got us
the Western Division championship as
long as as well as a first round bye in
the playoffs but of course will be
playing Norway in the first round and it
could be tough as the pro Chesley Final
Four is in Norway and they'll be gunning
for the win or he's playing in the back
row defense and he finally chased the
Queen's he's had enough and Domingues
has those two Center pawns that will be
the difference excuse me
all right so what's gonna happen
g5 takes takes Domingues is under 10
seconds he's gotta make a move
gotta make a move takes takes here we
have a checkmate coming up hopefully
somehow someway let's get a checkmate
I'm thinking a checkmate on a one rook
over to the a file oh it goes to the B
file pushes the pawn nice coming back to
her defense soup is trying to win Forks
the guys don't get 46 seconds Knight
attacks Knight takes the bishop Nick
takes and now it's a simple win for
Domingues Oh
Bishop takes is a led by brick c6 check
and we got right a toaster burger in the
hose and okay he's pushing the pawns
pushing the poems now we can take all
right can just keep pushing for seconds
they did take and here comes Bishop to
a5 check and that will do it that'll do
it here comes the Queen and uh it's over
soup a goes down valiant effort by soupy
and Geoffrey X wins as well it's a
crushing defeat by the st. Lewis
Archbishop's your Western Division
champions and we are the league leader
in points we will get the a1 slot we'll
get the first round bye in the protest
League playoffs and we'll be playing the
winner of Norway and India in the
quarterfinals so to back in sometime
around March 6th and we equip their
viewers that we needed to to telecast
that match it'll be right before the
candidates hopefully
we'll have our 2,700 team this team
obviously playing hopefully Fabiano will
play but all right but but watch this
commercial it's gonna be great Norway
the chess capital of Europe me angry and
Seibel with Magnus Carlsen
it's the protest League finals at chess
Party 2020 Caruana
so
boat s camera Rudolph chess bras an open
Fischer random chess tournament
will you be part of the world's biggest
chess party party 2020 hopefully we'll
be there and let's have a rundown of the
final standings so the final results it
was a great round for the archbishop's
as you saw we swept we swept even though
we had nothing really to play for but
now we have bragging rights over the
Armenia Eagles as we are the the league
leader in points I mean we won perfect
season so can't get enough join us
tonight at 6 p.m. we have the closing
ceremony other turns HUP congratulations
to the winner Grandmaster Canelo all
right so join us then I'm international
arbiter Mike comer st. Louis Archbishop
manager and I'm signing off hopefully
I'll see you in Norway this has been a
presentation of the st. Louis chess club